let me tell you just what's happened in
the last month had a cancer on my cheek
and they took out a three-inch hunk of
my cheek and then dug a little deeper it
was a malignant dangerous cancer but in
doing it they cut the ducts of saliva
that go to your mouth so now every time
I eat all the saliva that should go to
my mouth just comes pouring out from in
between the stitches on my cheek and
it's prevented healing because it's
always moist you know it doesn't dry up
or anything and they've gone back three
times to do surgery now and the last one
they had to cut some nerves that
paralyzed the left side of my mouth here
a little bit you you may not be able to
hear it but I can feel it it drives me
crazy but anyway this is what I'm
dealing with right now and if I sound a
little funny or whatever now you know
why and luckily I won't be eating while
I'm up here so that you won't have to
witness what happens when I eat I have
to use about ten pieces of paper towel
you know in this hand while I eat so
anyway when I get back next week they'll
be dealing with it surgically again and
keep me in your prayers that they can
tie those ducts off so that this won't
happen anymore but I just wanted to
share that with you I you know I came
out here I don't know six seven years
ago Danny I'll be telling that story and
and he got up in the san diego church to
begin a six-week tour that went from san
diego all the way up to vancouver canada
and I'm fixing my computer up in the
pulpit and I had a heart attack before I
opened my mouth and so went to the
hospital there in San Diego and had
stent put in and which they finally
found after waiting eight hours and
searching surgically for what happened
but then I continued on with the tour
you know and I felt I just felt I had to
do this and and God blessed and luckily
in the san diego church there was oak
was at oklahoma san diego i can't
remember but they were able to get some
things from online to show the crowd
that was there but i was in the hospital
for about four days and i tell you it's
all it all began with writing the omega
rebellion from the beginning of writing
that book it was just one thing after
another I'm not complaining I'm not
Jesus went through far worse to save all
of us right so I just look at it like
I'm sharing in what Jesus had to go
through to save me with we know we need
to share in the cross and that's what
this is all about we share in the cross
it's deaf now or deaf at the end right
let's take it now let's take it now all
right okay now I brought enough to talk
for six hours and you know I I have a
hard time trying to follow my notes if I
use overheads and things like that so I
and I know that all the other speakers
have all the goods they've got all the
evidence of what I want to talk about so
you'll see the evidence of things that I
say in what the other speakers present
they'll show you the proof I may just
say the way it is without having to
prove it because you know we could read
text statements from the spirit of
prophecy all night long
I don't want to do that
I want to talk to you about what's
happening in our beloved church I want
to talk to you about how we can be
overcomers Danny read it at a Revelation
chapter 12 verse 11 I think it is we
overcome by the word of our testimony do
you ever wonder what that means
we overcome by the word of our testimony
let's bow our heads for a word of Prayer
Lord we all have a testimony it may be
positive it may be negative we all need
a positive testimony we all need to be
able to say it was God who led me it was
your voice speaking to my heart
it was you who changed my life it was
you who brought me to the truth let me
tell you how Lord be with us tonight as
we think about these things as we as we
think about our own testimony and how
our testimony brings victory in our
lives in Jesus name we've all heard that
you know right we gain victory by the
word of our testimony by the word of God
and then you've got the martyrs crying
out from the ground win Lord when is our
blood gonna be avenged of course it's a
metaphor it wasn't the souls of the Dead
it was their blood in the ground that
was speaking a message to God when 50
million martyrs put to death by the
church in the world that the whole world
looks to for guidance looks to as the
genuine church 50 million martyrs that's
pretty tough
is that gonna happen again do we really
live every day thinking that that's
gonna happen again that kind of
persecution that took place it's gonna
happen again folks it is gonna happen
again
let me read you something great
controversy page 572 but Romanism as a
system is no more in harmony with the
gospel of Christ now that had any former
period in her history you know I was out
in Walla Walla just a couple of years
ago and I remember some you know very
well-known people saying you know the
Roman Catholic Church they changed
they're not like they used to be well if
they change let's just throw the great
controversy away and if you're gonna
throw the great controversy away what
other parts of the spirit of prophecy
are you gonna decide I don't want to
follow this I don't want to follow that
I don't want to follow this just make up
your own mind choose what you want right
can we do that listen she is employing
every device to extend her influence and
increase her power in preparation for a
fierce and determined conflict to regain
control of the world regain control of
the world what does it mean regain
regain what she had during the Dark Ages
when Kings bow down to her to
reestablish persecution that's her
desire to reestablish persecution those
50 million martyrs you know and to undo
all that Protestantism has done
Catholicism is gaining ground on every
side the great controversy page 572
well am I gonna believe that or not
here's an important principle there are
many people in the world that are just
totally absolutely unspiritual Satan
doesn't bother them he's already got
them then there are those that are
spiritual
so we're seeking truth right we're
looking for it and that's who he focuses
in on alright so we will fall under the
supernatural influences you know we
wrestle not against flesh and blood but
against principalities and powers from
the celestial spheres demons and angels
we're under the influence of either of
those two powers and how do we know I'm
sitting up here tonight and all of the
speakers for this symposium are telling
you what we believe to be the truth but
the teachings that we expose the people
that believe in that will turn around
and say we're a mistaken how do you know
you are under the influence of a
supernatural power whether you like it
or not but thank God we have the spirit
of prophecy okay it's a standard I can't
trust myself you can't trust yourself I
don't care if you've got a photographic
mind have memorized everything in the
spirit of prophecy and have memorized
the Bible from Genesis to Revelation
that won't keep you safe because we're
warned if God has any new light to give
to his people he will give it to them
without there having to go to those who
are in darkness and era now you know
what that means folks for 50 years our
church has fallen into this trap of
going back to the very church --is that
God has delivered us from in order to
learn new things to apply to our
spiritual lives and that's exactly what
the spirit of prophecy says don't do it
it is those who heed the counsel in the
spirit of prophecy
it will not fall into the Omega
deception while those it refused to heed
the the counsel that God has given us
they're the ones that go walk stop and
barrel into this stuff it's exciting to
them God led me to Isaiah chapter 31
night in answer to this whole thing oh I
was up praying in the middle of the
night in the middle of writing the Omega
rebellion Lord why why do these people
who are educated they have the spirit of
prophecy they've been through our
schools what is it that causes them to
go back to the very schools that I know
I was delivered from and many had been
delivered from why did why did they do
it you know I got up and the word that
was in my mind was rebellion because I'm
going to tell you another story right
after this one about how God spoke to me
about rebellion but this I got up off my
knees after saying why are there those
in rebellion that have little leaders in
our church but no the spirit of prophecy
that haven't they got every one of the
little red books in their library and it
wasn't very difficult for me when I
started to look at that to find all the
counsel I needed to flee
this kind of stuff that's in the
emerging church spiritual formation well
I I got up off my knees and I think the
word rebellion was the last word out of
my mouth and and I don't recommend this
for a way to study the Bible but I sat
down on my favorite chair with my dog
next to me and I took my Bible out and
it opened and they're open to Isaiah
chapter 30 and I looked down woe to the
rebellious that says whoa that was the
last word just out of my mouth I'm
asking about those that are in rebellion
in the church this is Isaiah 30 woe to
the rebellious children saith the Lord
that they take counsel but not from me
well who did they take counsel from that
cover with a covering but not of my
spirit another spirit of some kind that
they may add sin to sin well what is
this other spirit that walk to go down
into Egypt we would say Babylon today
all right they've go back to Babylon to
take counsel from the gods of Babylon
rather than the Spirit of God but why
did they do this I'm reading this now
and it's like every text is answering my
prayer therefore shall two strength of
Pharaoh be your shame and trust in the
shadow of Egypt your confusion see the
leaders in our church that have gone
back to Babylon to get their Advanced
Education they're the ones that have
brought this spiritual formation back
into our church okay that's where it's
come from
why look at verse 5 they were all
ashamed of people that could not profit
them nor be a help nor profit but is
shame
and also a reproach people in our church
that look at our own church and are
ashamed of it they want the stuff that's
out there that's the problem
it looks so good out there the churches
are growing like crazy everybody's have
any spiritual experiences coming into
the presence of God folks they're not
going into the presence of God they're
going into an altered state of
consciousness and I have been there I
know what it's like oh it's fascinating
it's fascinating we'll talk more about
that but you know why there's such a
thing as contemplative prayer and
centering prayer and mandra's you know
why those things exist because something
mentally occurs when you practice those
things right now if you could count that
fast you could count if you're wide
awake which I hope you all are thoughts
flying across your consciousness at
anywhere from 15 to 60 per second that's
fast and the way the mind works is it it
reaches out and it grabs the thought my
car I gotta check the tires I gotta
change the oil
thoughts about my car begin flowing at
that rate and I just keep picking and
choosing with my consciousness this way
our minds work we attract thoughts
related to whichever one we chose to
think about right when you focus the
mind on one thing to the exclusion of
everything else like a mantra or a word
out of the Bible or a phrase out of the
Bible those thoughts slow down
you can do the same thing by smoking
marijuana
and I say that as a warning
marijuana chemically does the same thing
put you in a trance-like state where
demons can communicate with you all
right you don't know what's going on you
just had a time dilation where you
thought the commercial was the program
you know but it's because your mind
slowed down all right things changed up
there and you know this is right out of
the mouths of a spirit medium my spirit
teacher spirit medium teacher I asked
her about alcohol I asked her about
marijuana you see she said you know the
spirits never say anything bad about
marijuana that's right they don't
because they know it's a pathway to get
into your mind it automatically does the
same thing that contemplative prayer
does that centering does that focusing
the mind and the mind's eye on on an
object of flame anything when you focus
the mind on one thing to the exclusion
of all else your breathing sensations
whatever or you listen to some leader
leading you through a guided meditation
who says close your eyes and think of
this and then think that he's
controlling that focusing up here and
you're going down into this corridor of
the mind where demons can speak to you
they can't read your mind but they can
speak to you you go to a psychic medium
or something like that you know and
you'll be told oh you were just thinking
about this and they're right and you're
amazed this person has the ability to
read my mind
no but the demons in control of that
person and you have the ability to give
both of you the same thought so you get
a thought and then the medium gets a
thought and verbalizes it and it's
sounds like they have some power and
they think they have that power but they
don't they're being used by a familiar
spirit that's how all this works and
when you go into the silence I was into
the silence I was doing automatic
writing I was into the silence you know
where I saw my guru whatever whatever
religion you are when you get into the
silence that's the deception that these
supernatural powers will deceive you
with you know if you're a Christian
you'll see Jesus it was a pastor down in
Georgia I remember that told the story
about how he was praying in the
sanctuary
remember 2530 years ago there was
praying in the sanctuary trend that we
got into well I heard the story about
what he went through and I called him
and I you know I said tell me - tell me
what happened is it this is what I heard
that you were praying in the sanctuary
in the most holy place and your dead
father appeared to you and he said yeah
that's right and I said what happened he
goes well I said get thee behind me
Satan I knew the truth about the state
of the Dead so you know I claimed that
promise in the image of my dead father
just disappeared and I said well let's
you know that sounds good but so you
believe that Satan appeared is your dead
father and he goes yeah but what if he
would have appeared as Jesus Christ
instead of your dead father would you
have said get thee behind me Satan now
and he was silent he understood he got
it I'd rather not be anywhere where any
kind of a demon can appear as anybody to
me right
don't go there well the silence is the
place to go to have experiences like
that and the people who go there feel
they've come into the presence of
I've been there I know what it's like
your thoughts stop and you become an
observer and I saw thoughts that other
people were having
it was a strange fascinating and
mysterious experience but it scared me
praise God for the Holy Spirit I know it
was the Spirit of God that made me get
so frightened I had to break the whole
trance I was in it's no good and then I
thought because I went to the spirit
medium I was gonna die for the next
three days was a big blur I had my
sister Gail holding her hand on my chest
make sure I could continue breathing you
know but I was convinced that I lost
eternal life because of what I did you
know I really felt that desolation of
having no hope the same desolation that
Jesus felt on the cross I'm sure it was
just a little tiny piece of it but he
had no hope not one ray of hope it says
in the Bible not one ray of hope he
could not see through the portals of the
tomb Wow then why did he do it
have you ever thought of that if he
couldn't see through the portals of the
tomb and he had not one ray of hope why
did he do it each one of you has to ask
yourself that why did he do it I want to
share something with you now that's the
deepest that I've been able to get in my
own experience he couldn't stand the
thought of being in heaven without you
he said if I step down from this cross
even though I have no hope nobody will
be saved his love for the human race his
lovely
was greater than his love for his own
existence and he's God he's God and he
said if I if I step down if I stop this
whole process there will be no human
saved none and he wasn't willing to live
forever without us without you just two
if he were the only one that's the way
it would be right he wasn't willing to
live without one of the leaders of the
emerging Church of the one project
brother and sister seventh-day
Adventists who are confused don't
understand what they're doing oh my god
we've gotta pray for these people and
pray that they're not in rebellion
because Ellen White said she doubts that
there's ever a cure for true rebellion
that's a frightening statement rebellion
is as the sin of what witchcraft related
the sin of witchcraft
do you know a witch who knows that
they're not doing something wrong I
don't I've met some witches they know
it's wrong I mean I came home from the
spirit medium and grabbed my Bible and
it opened to Deuteronomy 18 verse 11 it
said they're not there shall not be
found a man among you anyone who and
then it named all of these different
things witchcraft astrology necromancy
or a necromancer a necromancer is one
who communicates with the dead I just
had a message from a dead spirit at a
seance an hour before and I read that
when I got home that's why I thought
I've done it I'm finna I'm finished you
know and that's it I swore off religion
forever I said that's it I can't do this
anymore
then I became a disciple of a Hindu
about a week later so I couldn't stop I
just you know this was obsessive for
both Rosalie and I you know it just was
like this was our life God was leading
tomorrow morning I'm gonna share the
testimony of how God led us to this
church but folks we need to pray for
these people that are out there that are
confused over this they don't seem to
see the counsel that I talked about
before that if God has any new light for
us as a people the same counsel to
Solomon don't mingle with the
Philistines you know don't think that
you're gonna win them over by taking
them as wives you know might have looked
good in the beginning but look how it
ended for Solomon you know it just God
was trying to protect his people and he
was saying because He loves us so much
if I've got any new light for you I'll
give it to you I called you out of those
Babylonian churches you don't have to go
back to them thinking that you're gonna
find the way of salvation or a way to
improve your spiritual life it's not
gonna happen
and if you do it this is what I was
getting at before Lord just brought me
back there because I never finished the
whole concept all right I was talking
about if you have the whole Bible
memorized and all the spirit of prophecy
memorized that doesn't mean anything
when you violate the counsel that God
has given us and you do not heed the
counsel there's a world of supernatural
beings and the angels that protect you
have to step back and the evil angels
are right there and they say they made
their choice you have got to allow us to
have
says to his mind or her mind that's
what's going on and then we're told that
once they have access to our mind they
begin to weave the threads of their
thoughts into our thoughts so that the
things we used to love we hate and the
things we used to be hating and flee
from we begin to love oh I just heard
this speaker a Rick Warren I just heard
this speaker oh fantastic ideas well
you're not even supposed to be listening
to it don't even listen she says and
when we listen we've made the decision
to allow evil angels to come and begin
to weave the threads of their thoughts
into our lives we don't know what's
going on it is a branch of hypnosis
Ellen White says the same hypnosis that
was used on Eve in the Garden of Eden
and why and how did he get hypnotized
did she do contemplative prayer did she
do centering so that she would enter
into that hypnotic state no she talked
to the devil she didn't heed the warning
God told her don't leave Adams side
don't get in front of that tree by
yourself you won't be able to handle it
she was told that they were both told
that but she decided to do it and then
when she heard the voice coming out of
the serpent this beautiful creature I
can't stand these pictures where I see a
snake you know a snake was a beautiful
flying creature subtle hardly ever seen
in the Garden of Eden every once in a
while oh he goes one of the Serpent's
beautiful flying the color of burnished
gold that's why he chose that creature
because he knew that if Eve saw that
creature
she wouldn't take her eyes off it
cuz they never saw it just every once in
a while a fleeting glance and here it
was it landed right in the tree in front
of her picked the fruit and started
eating right in front of us
delicious and I'm not dead yeah he has
God said you should not eat of the tree
of every garden in the Garden of Eden
you know yeah God said don't even touch
it
we died she started to talk to Satan
never you'll never win ever he's a lot
smarter than you are and he has all
kinds of supernatural power to influence
you and if you don't have the protection
of your angels they're in trouble we are
either under the influence of our
heavenly angels that watch over us and
protect us or we're not and if we're not
it's the evil angels that are
influencing us and weaving the fine
threads of their thoughts into ours
this is a battle that you cannot win on
your own you've got to choose who it is
that you're going to allow into your
mind are you gonna make all your
judgments based on your intelligence and
the fact that you think you know
everything I hope not
because we don't know anything without
the Spirit of God
we're just spiritual things a confusion
to us all right so if we see things
truthfully the Spirit of God may have
been influencing us for many many years
but if we choose not to heed the
warnings are the powers moving and
that's what's happening in the church
today other powers are moving in and you
need to make your choices you need to
choose
one of the first books that I remember
becoming an Adventist was the shaking of
Adventism remember that book shaking of
you know what causes the shaking error
Jesus the head of the church allows
error to come into the church folks the
emerging church didn't sneak into the
Adventist Church Jesus permitted it he
is in total control of his church he's
omniscient okay he's no longer on the
present but the Holy Spirit has taken
that work but he's omniscient he knows
everything there wasn't something taking
place in some far corner of the church
in this world that he doesn't know about
if it's in the church he has permitted
it to be in the church for a reason
to drive us to study to drive us to
study these things on our own you know
in the beginning of writing the Omega
rebellion I was brokenhearted Lord how
are we gonna get this out of the church
and then God finally helped me and he's
just communicated to me you don't have
to worry about getting it out of the
church you know it's the it's his angels
that separate the wheat and the tares
not me you not you but our people God's
children need to have the truth so they
can make a choice and that's what all
these books are about out there
okay people who have written what they
believe is the truth and I started this
off by saying well how do we know well
is what's written in those books backed
by the spirit of prophecy in Scripture
because the stuff from the emerging
Church they flee from the spirit of
prophecy in Scripture oh we don't want
to talk about that that separates us no
doctrine in the emergent church because
doctrine separates absolutely doctrine
separates that's what it's men
to do so when you hear no doctrine or we
don't want to push that one out the back
door you don't need to listen to what's
coming okay
you cannot know Jesus without doctrine
they're inseparable the Lord and his
teachings are inseparable so when people
say they don't want to push doctrine
they're saying with they don't want to
push Jesus all right how do you know
about Jesus what he's like what the
truth is by doctrine that's what
doctrine is that's why Jesus is inter
woven with every doctrine so don't fall
for that trap that says oh well doctrine
we've had enough doctrine you never have
enough doctrine because doctrine reveals
Jesus is character who he is
is it really 2009 all right I want to
share a couple stories because I want
you to see how the word of your
testimony gives you victory the word of
your testimony gives you victory in life
that's what the scripture says before I
retired I was pastor of the Hilton Head
and Buford seventh-day Adventist
churches Carolina Conference my head
elder was Ken Holland some of you may
remember that name he was the editor of
the signs before Marvin Moore okay and
he was in the publishing work all his
life he retired to Hilton Head and he
was my head older for 10 years he died
when I was 89 Thursday but during those
10 years any time that I had a sermon
where spiritualism was involved with it
you know our inter woven in some way
that on the way out of church after
church ken was a very soft-spoken man he
grabbed my hand and he leaned over and
he'd say Rick you gotta write a book
about this okay
thanks Ken I'll work on it for 10 years
I'm not a writer I am NOT a writer
technical stuff chemical stuff yeah but
that was a different life and he must
have said that to me a hundred times and
then he died and about a year went by
and I'm in the office at church alone on
my knees praying you know just praying
knelt down to pray and do the normal
things that you do when you pray then
all of a sudden everything kind of
stopped got quiet and I hear Rick you
gotta write a book about this why it
just came out of nowhere I didn't go to
the Witch of Endor and it wasn't Ken but
it was God bringing Ken's voice back to
my mind and I knew that it was not from
me
and I knew God was telling me not an
easy thing to write a book it's not you
know ask Rosalie anyway okay I knew I
had to do it I got out everything all my
notes all the papers that I had my desk
was piled up to here with all kinds of
stuff and I started research I wasn't
sure exactly which way I was going to go
but I knew I had to write a book about
what was going on in the church after
about an hour I hear somebody open the
door of the church I hear some people
come in they're talking and I saw a
flash
and I knew I had to get up and go out
and greet these visitors so I went out
to the foyer and there were two couples
and they said oh what a beautiful church
you know we found ourselves driving you
know and we came across it to your mind
if we'd go around and take some pictures
and I said no it's fine go go right
ahead I said if you need me I showed
them around a little bit and I went back
in the office and about ten minutes
later I look up and here is one of the
ladies from the two couples leaning on
the door looking at my desk and I felt
like well she probably thinks I should
be committed somewhere you know because
it really was a mess she said what are
you doing and I said well actually I'm
doing some research for a long overdue
book Oh what's good what's it about and
I didn't expect her to know anything
about it and I said well it's actually
gonna be about the Alpha and the Omega
oh we need a book about that and she
walks across puts her hand out and says
my name is so-and-so and I'm the vice
president of Pacific Press Oh after ten
years on the very morning that I start
researching this book she spends the
next hour and a half telling me how to
do it who the contact names the whole
deal she was amazed she's an old friend
of Ken Holland's they were on their way
from London to LA back to California
their plane had a set down in Savannah
with a problem and they couldn't get a
plane till the next day so they decided
we're gonna rent a car and just go
sightseeing and we wound up in front of
you at church 35 miles from the Savannah
Airport and we said oh look at this
church beautiful let's go in and they
came in just when they came in and when
I told them that I have been struggling
with this book for ten years and I just
started this morning
she knew the gauntlet and
then she knew why they had to land in
Savannah you know this was just it was
evidence to me that God wanted me to
write this book okay so I started
writing it wasn't much after that that
the book was complete so I'm going to
talk some about that tomorrow but some
old friends
dear friends people who I considered
mentors in our lives
stop by my church when Sabbath and I
decided to touch on some of the things
because I knew where they were going
they were going up to Myrtle Beach to a
seminar with John Ortberg and George
Barna now these are two people very much
into the emerging church into mysticism
I knew they were headed that way so I
thought I'm going to touch on what I've
been writing for the last year and I
touched on it
and it got them so angry and upset with
me that they were actually literally
raising their voices at me in the foyer
of my church in front of my church
members and the accusation was Rick
don't you think that all that
involvement that you've had and
spiritualism has affected your mind I
said no and I spent the next week or two
writing all the evidence from the spirit
of prophecy explaining to them how God
led me so no I don't think it affected
my mind I have a testimony where God led
me step by step to write this book and I
know it was God I know it was God you
can think what you want but I know from
the word of my testimony and this gives
me victory over your criticism and
accusations it's meaningless to me
because God moved providentially in my
life
and I know I did what he wanted me to do
and I wrote all of these explanations
from the spirit of prophecy pointing out
the evil in this teaching and the only
email I got back was Rick how's your
prayer life an insult and insult and
then at the Carolina camp meeting this
person the the lady of the couple in one
day three people and they emailed me and
told me that how they ran across this
person and offered her the Omega
rebellion she wouldn't take it the
second one she wouldn't take it
the third one offered by Ron my firt
many of you know who Ron Knifer it is he
said the fist went down I will never
read that book okay okay you see this is
what in a way we are all up against with
people into the emerging church they
don't have the spirit of prophecy on
their side they don't have scripture on
their side you know if you go to law
school you're very quickly learn if you
got the truth argue the truth and you're
a winner
if you don't have the truth destroy the
reputation of your opponent criticize
everything they do so that nobody will
believe what they say and that's what we
do run into those of us that are
involved in this warfare right now we do
run into that okay but you have a
testimony okay those of us that are
involved here that have been meeting
that will be speaking tomorrow we have a
testimony God has worked in our lives
in such a way that we have seen the
Providence involved tomorrow morning I'm
going to tell you the story about how
Danny was involved in this whole thing
you see when I finished the Omega
rebellion I'm gonna end with this now
it's two minutes to nine when I finished
the Omega rebellion I didn't even get
into the sacraments in the Roman
Catholic Church I'll do that tomorrow
morning okay but when I finish the Omega
rebellion I told the Lord I said lord I
do not want to have any part in getting
this book published because I could get
the timing wrong I want you to bring the
book out when you want the book to be
out and we waited a year and a half
imagine what that felt like here I see
people being deceived over and over
constantly and I got this book but I I
didn't want to go back on my agreement
with God
so you bring it out you bring it out
when you're ready for it to be brought
out it was a year and a half later that
I was sitting at the Dome in Atlanta
when Ted Wilson was elected president
and he gave us go forward sermon and he
said don't go outside the church to
learn spiritual formation and I said the
tears I said this is what God has been
waiting for so that we have a conference
president who understands this battle
and what's going on and it was I don't
know a short time thereafter that I got
some very persistent person from
California that calls me over and over
and over his name is Danny and I didn't
know who he was he's hiding tomorrow
I'll tell you the rest of the story okay
in Sabbath school but you know I wanted
to end tonight I was gonna end with that
but I'll start tomorrow with that and
I'm gonna end right now with mysticism
do you know that you earn God's grace in
the Roman Catholic Church when you
perform the sacraments did you know that
that's what the sacraments are they are
a method a way to receive the grace of
God that's what the Eucharist is all
about every sacrament is meant to bring
you in a mystical experience and receive
the grace of God by the performance of
those works well in the Protestant
churches the sacraments don't work that
well but the silence does it's the same
mysticism it replaces the sacraments in
Roman Catholicism you understand this is
the emerging church it goes right back
to the Desert Fathers who knew to go
into an altered state of mind in order
to get into that silence where they
would come into the presence of God that
was Ignatius loyal as downfall you know
he was a contemporary of Martin Luther's
Luther went back to Scripture Loyola
couldn't stand the idea of sin he hated
it he wanted to see goodness everywhere
instead of having to overcome sin he
didn't want to see sin at all and you
know if you want the gospel to fit what
you want the gospel to be Satan I'll
supply it right away he'll give it to
you well that's the emerging Church
theology that's what I exposed in the
book meeting when I studied that
theology I said this is Roman
Catholicism it's the Spirit of God in
every human being God made us all right
so the reasoning in the book that they
use in the emerging churches
in the one project anyway as their Bible
the green chord dream written by dr.
Alex Bryant and I don't speak this
against dr. Bryan at all I just wish
that he would read and come to grips
with what he wrote in his book which is
that because God created us all
everybody's a Christian that's
universalism it's Universal Moltmann
okay Moltmann was the theologian who he
depended on for his philosophy for his
theology and he's a Universalist we're
all gonna be saved and if we're all
gonna be saved who needs an atonement
who needs the second coming this is
where Moltmann is coming from all right
and all the theology of the one project
comes from Jurgen Moltmann not the
spirit of prophecy not one mention in
the green cord dream except Ellen
White's dream but all the council in the
book is for advocates of spiritual
formation it's hard to understand but
it's a rejection of the spirit of
prophecy
why is was I saying a thirty true were
they ashamed of the church are they
ashamed of our church because we're not
doing the things that they're doing out
there and the Babylonian churches we
just need to pray for these folks
they're our brothers and sisters and it
should be the burden of every one of our
hearts for them to be converted back to
understand the truth that God has given
us in the Adventist Church this is God's
church never criticize God's church ever
Jesus loved this church he gave his life
for it I mean Ellen White even said that
I haven't considered
General Conference to be the voice of
God for the last three years those are
her words but did she lead the church
did she speak bad of it no no because
she knows it's the object of the one
object of God's supreme regard Jesus
loves this church he's the head of this
church and he's aware of everything that
happens so we don't ever want to
criticize the church but Satan brings
people into the church and because of
free will everybody that makes bad
choices in the church doesn't get thrown
right out Jesus gives them the
opportunity to see into their own heart
that's what the Holy Spirit does so God
leads them he gives them time so are we
gonna have false teaching in the church
absolutely but we don't want to
criticize the church because of it but
when the time is right and God speaks to
our hearts and we need to stand up and
point the finger not at the person at
the teaching the teaching is wrong okay
and don't let anybody ever tell you that
well you didn't use Matthew 18 you
didn't go to them first what am I to
travel the whole world to the people
that are speaking this error and speak
with each one of them individually no
Matthew 18 is for a local congregation
it's to keep the unity among the
brethren and sisters in a local church
when a person has sinned against another
person well they haven't sinned against
me I'm speaking to a theology that's
being preached all over the world
tomorrow I'll share what else to say